Você já parou para pensar por que alguns
japoneses parecem ter descoberto o
segredo longevidade enquanto a gente
aqui no Ocidente envelhece que nem leite
fora da geladeira? A resposta pode estar
num pigmento vermelho extraído de algas
microscópicas que t o poder antioxidante
6.000 vezes maior que a vitamina C.
6.000 mil vezes, gente, eu aposto que
você nunca ouviu falar direito sobre
isso. Hoje vamos destrinchar a taxina,
esse carotenoide que está revolucionando
a forma como a ciência enxerga proteção
celular, rejuvenescimento da pele e
energia mitocondrial. Se você acha que
está bem servido com o seu
multivitamínico basicão, prepare-se para
descobrir que está deixando dinheiro na
mesa da sua saúde. Eu vou te contar uma
história que mudou a minha forma de
enxergar antioxidantes. Há uns 3 anos eu
estava no consultório atendendo uma
paciente de 52 anos que se queixava de
fadiga crônica. Aquela sensação de estar
arrastando o saco de cimento para todo
lado. Examiroide normais, hemograma OK,
cortisol dentro dos parâmetros. Eu
poderia ter feito o que 90% dos médicos
fazem, receitar o antidepressivo, mandar
para casa. Mas a abordagem funcional me
ensinou a olhar mais fundo. Quando
investiguei a função mitocondrial dela
através de teste de ácidos orgânicos,
descobri que as mitocôndrias estavam
literalmente apagadas, produzindo
energia com eficiência de um Fusca 1972,
tentando competir na Fórmula 1. Foi aí
que eu incluí a tachaina no protocolo
dela na dose de 12 mg por dia. Três
meses depois ela voltou dizendo que
tinha esquecido como era ter energia de
verdade e não era placebo, era
bioquímica pura. Mas antes de te contar
os protocolos que eu uso na clínica,
preciso que você entenda o que diabos é
essa tal de asta e porque ela não é só
mais um modismo do mercado suplementos.
Asa chantina é um carotenoide na família
das chantofilas, produzido
principalmente pela microalga, hematocos
pluviales. É aquele pigmento vermelho
alaranjado que você vê no salão
selvagem, no camarão, na lagosta. Esses
bichos não produzem as tachantina, eles
acumulam porque comem as algas que
produzem. E aqui vai um dado
interessante. Um estudo publicado em
2024 no Journal Nutrients mostrou que a
Atachantina tem uma capacidade de
neutralização de radicais livres até
6.000 vezes maior que a vitamina C, 800
vezes mais potente que a cozema que é 10
e 550 vezes mais eficaz que a vitamina
E. Mas o que a torna realmente especial
não é só a potência bruta, é a forma
como ela se posiciona nas membranas
celulares. Diferente de outros
antioxidantes que ficam só de um lado da
membrana, a taxhantina atravessa
completamente a bicamada lipídica,
protegendo tanto a parte interna quanto
a externa da célula. Mais importante
ainda, ela cruza a barreira
imatocefálica e a barreira imatetiniana,
chegando onde a maioria dos
antioxidantes não conseguem chegar. Isso
significa proteção direta pro cérebro e
pros olhos, órgãos extremamente
vulneráveis ao estresse oxidativo. Um
trabalho de 2025 publicado recentemente
confirmou que a taçina se acumula em
tecidos neurais, estimula a produção de
BDNF, o fator neurotrófico derivado do
cérebro, que é essencial paraa
neuroplasticidade e sobrevivência
neuronal. Agora vamos falar de
mitocôndrias porque é aí que a mágica
realmente acontece. As mitocôndrias são
usinas de energia das nossas células,
mas também são as maiores produtoras de
espécies reativas de oxigênio durante o
processo de produção da ATP. Com
passados anos, esse bombardeio constante
de radicais livres deteriora, detona as
membranas mitocondriais, reduz a
eficiência energética e acelera o
envelhecimento celular. A asta chantina
tem uma propriedade única. Ela se
incorpora diretamente nas membranas
mitocondriais, estabilizando a estrutura
e protegendo os lipídios e proteínas do
dano oxidativo. Estudos recentes 2024
desmam suplementação com as chantantina
aumenta o potencial de membrana
mitocondrial e melhora a produção de
ATP, traduzindo-se em melhor desempenho
físico e resistência à fadiga. Um
trabalho publicado em junho de 2024 na
revista Nutrients focado em atletas de
endurance mostrou que a taxantina não é
só para melhorar a capacidade
antioxidanteógena, mas também aumenta os
níveis de gluta no sangue total, como
também acelera a recuperação da dor
muscular tardia e melhora marcadores
cardiorrespiratórios como frequência
cardíaca submaxima durante corrida e
ciclismo. Traduzindo, suas mitocôndrias
trabalham melhor, você produz mais
energia com menos desgaste e o corpo se
recupera mais rápido. E olha que
interessante, a pesquisa também sugeriu
que a taxantina pode promover biogênese
mitocondrial, ou seja, criação de novas
mitocôndrias. Isso é absolutamente
revolucionário quando falamos de
longevidade e prevenção de doenças
crônicas, mas é a pele, porque eu sei
que muita gente que está me assistindo
agora está mais interessada em como isso
vai fazer a pele parecer 10 anos mais
nova do que em bioquímica mitocondrial.
E tá tudo bem, porque os dados sobre
pele são absolutamente impressionantes.
Uma metaanálise sistemática de 2024
publicada no Frontiers em Cardiovascular
Medicine, avaliou múltiplos ensaios
clínicos randomizados controlados por
place para place parabo e concluiu que a
suplementação oral de asta chantantina
na faixa de 3 a 6 mg por dia, por 6 a 8
semanas melhora significativamente a
hidratação, elasticidade, textura da
pele, reduzindo profundidade de rugas e
manchas de idade. Não é efeito cosmético
superficial, é reestruturação dêmica
profunda. E como é que funciona? Asta
chanentina ativa a via de sinalização
TGF beta, estimulando a síntese de
colágeno, ao mesmo tempo que suprime a
via NFK beta, inibindo inflamação e
degradação do colágeno pela
metaloproteinase de matriz, a famosa
mmp1. Além disso, ela oferece
fotoproteção contra danos induzidos por
radiação
estudo de 2018 publicado na Nutrients
mostrou que 6 mg de astaçantina por dia
em homens saudáveis melhorou rugas,
elasticidade, perda de água,
transepidérmica, conteúdo de umidade e
nível de oleosidade sea em apenas seis
semanas. Gente, estamos falando de um
composto que age de dentro para fora.
Não é crime milagroso que você passa e
torce para funcionar. é bioquímica
celular real, alterando a estrutura da
sua pele. Um trabalho russo de 2017
publicado no Journal of Dietary
Supplements foi ainda mais específico.
Voluntários de meia idade suplementados
com 4 mg de astaina por dia durante 4
semanas apresentaram redução
significativa nos níveis plasmáticos de
malundial deído, que é um biomarcador de
estresse oxidativo sistêmico e reversão
de alterações morfológicas relacionadas
à idade nos componentes residuais da
superfície da pele. Então eles
literalmente documentaram que a
suplementação reverteu mudança de
envelhecimentos visíveis na microscopia.
Isso não é propaganda, é ciência
revisada por pares. Agora vamos falar de
dosagem, porque é aqui que a maioria das
pessoas erra completamente. A maior
parte dos estudos clínicos trabalha com
doses entre 4 e 12 mg por dia, sendo 6
mg considerado o ponto ideal para
benefícios em queima de gordura,
performance e recuperação. Mas quando a
gente fala de intervenções mais
agressivas pra fadiga crônica, disfunção
mitocondrial severa ou proteção
neurológica intensa, eu pessoalmente uso
12 mg por dia no consultório. Um estudo
japonês de 2024 sobre pacientes
pré-diabéticos mostrou que 12 mg de
áreos de asta chanontina por 12 semanas
reduziram significativamente os níveis
de glicose aos 30 minutos do teste oral
de tolerância da glicose e diminuíram a
hemoglobina glicada. Mais do que isso,
melhorou o índice de matsuda e a
resistência insulínica hepática,
indicando efeitos benéficos na prevenção
de diabetes, indivíduos com hemogumina
agricada entre 5,6 e 6,4. Doses de até
40 mg por dia foram testadas em estudos
de segurança e são bem toleradas com
apenas alguns efeitos adversos, leves,
transitórios. Mas eu não recomendo
começar com doses altas. Comece com 6 mg
por dia, pelo menos 8 semanas para
avaliar sua resposta individual. E aqui
vai uma dica de ouro. Asta chantina é um
carotenol de lipossolúvel, ou seja,
significa que a absorção melhora
drasticamente quando você toma junto com
uma refeição que tem a gordura. Então,
um punhado de castanhas, uma colher de
azeite, um abacate, sem gordura você
está jogando dinheiro no lixo porque a
biodisponibilidade cai para quase nada.
Outra coisa importante, nem toda a
sachantina é igual. A asta chantina
sintética usada principalmente na
aquicultura, para deixar o salmão de
cativeiro com aquela cor alaranjada, tem
uma estrutura molecular diferente da
natural e menor atividade biológica.
Quando você for comprar, procure por
asta chantina natural derivada do
hematococos pluviales, de preferência
com certificação de terceiros como USP
ou Consumer Lab. Marcas como asta Real,
que é uma das mais estudadas
cientificamente, ou Biasting, são opções
confiáveis. E cuidado com produtos que
não especificam a fonte ou a
concentração exata de ascentantina. O
mercado dos suplementos tá cheio de
porcaria subfaturada. Vamos falar agora
dos efeitos cardiovasculares, porque
isso é crucial paraa galera que está
preocupada com longividade de verdade. A
doença cardiovascular continua sendo a
principal causa de morte relacionada ao
envelhecimento. A asta chantina
demonstrou de melhorar os perfis
lipídicos, reduzindo triglicerídeos,
aumentando a HDL colesterol, além de
reduzir a oxidação da LDL colesterol. Um
trabalho publicado no Future Cardiology
mostrou que a taciantina melhora a
eficiência mitocondrial nas células
cardíacas, essencial para manter a
função cardíaco durante o
envelhecimento. Em populações idosas, a
suplementação mostrou reduziu o risco de
aterosclerose. E tem mais, ela modula
vias de sinalização conservadas
evolutivamente que afetam longevidade,
incluindo a via NRF2/AAR,
que aumenta a produção de enzimas
antioxidantes como glutationa, ativação
de FOX O3, que promove o reparo de DNA e
resistência ao estresse. Também indução
de autofagia via PHA4 e UP regulation ou
ou UP regulação de LC32, facilitando
renovação celular e supressão de
informação através do down regulation de
NFK beta e citocinas pró-inflamatórias
como é o caso TNF alfa. Esses mecanismos
sinergizam para retardar as marcas
características do envelhecimento:
instabilidade genômica, disfunção
mitocondrial, inflamação crônica. Um
estudo de 2024 publicado na revista Gero
Science realizado em múltiplos centros
mostrou que as taxantina aumentou a
longividade camundongos machos em 12%
que é um achado extremamente
significativo. Embora não tenha afetado
fêmeas o que não é incomum nesse modelo.
Os resultados consistentes em machos
sugerem que a asta chantina pode
desempenhar um papel relevante no
envelhecimento humano. Óbvio que estudos
em humanos ainda são limitados a
desfechos intermediários, como saúde da
pele e perfis lipídicos, mas a extensão
de 12% na vida útil de camundongos
fornece base racional convincente para
estudos de longo prazo em humanos e
especialmente
dado o perfil de segurança excepcional
da esta chantina. E tem um fator
cerebral que para mim pessoalmente é o
mais importante por causa do histórico
familiar de Alhammer que eu tenho.
Quatro parentes meus desenvolveram
demência. Então, proteção neurológica
para mim não é luxo, é necessidade. A
asta chantina cruza a barreira em
matecefálica e se acumula em tecidos
neuronais, onde regula positivamente o
BDNF, o brain derived neurotropic
factor, que é uma proteína crítica paraa
sobrevivência e plasticidade neuronal.
Então, estudos pré-clínicos mostraram
que ela reduz dano oxidativo a lipídios,
proteínas de DNA em cérebros
envelhecidos, enquanto melhora a função
mitocondrial. Um review de 2023 destacou
que a as taxina pode ativar vias
genéticas específicas e promover
regeneração, crescimento de células
nervosas cerebrais adultas. Esses
efeitos podem retardar doenças
neurodegenativas. Por exemplo, em
modelos de roedores, a asta chantina
melhorou desempenho cognitivo e reduziu
placas de betamilode associadas a doença
de Alzheimer. O composto também modula
as vias em Bitor, PI3K, que influenciam
affagia, processo de limpeza celular que
declina com a idade. Promovendo a
autofagia, a taciantina ajuda a remover
organelas danificadas e proteínas,
mantendo saúde neuronal ao longo do
tempo. Isso é fundamental porque o
acúmulo de lixo celular é uma das
principais causas de neurodegenação. E
olha, não estou dizendo que a sua
chantina é a cura do Alzheimer, longe
disso, mas dentro de um protocolo
multifatorial de neuroproteção, ela é
uma peça importante. Tem também um
efeito anti-inflamatório sistêmico que
não pode ser ignorado. Inflamação
crônica de baixo grau, tal do inflameng
é reconhecido como um dos principais
motores de envelhecimento e
desenvolvimento de doenças. A asta
chantina demonstrou reduzir marcadores
inflamatórios chave que inclui proteína
serrativa a oito hidroxi 2 de
zoóxiguanosina que são ambos intimamente
religados ao envelhecimento e riscos de
saúde a longo prazo. Um estudo publicado
em 2025 na Molécilos avaliou
propriedades antiframatórias da
sarentina em várias condições crônicas e
agudas, incluindo doenças
neurodegenativas renais aáticas
relacionadas à pele e aos olhos, além de
distúbios gastrointestinais. A eficácia
terapêutica está associada a
propriedades antioxidante,
antiinflamatória, antiapoptótica e de
melhora da neuroplasticidade. Então ela
muda várias vias, incluindo PI3K HT,
NRF2,
NFK beta, ERK12,
JNK, P38 MPK e JAK2 STAT 3. Agora vamos
ser honesto sobre uma coisa. Tem muito
médico por aí que torce o nariz paraa
suplementação dizendo que é tudo
besteira, tudo placebo, que você
consegue tudo pela alimentação, tá?
Vamos fazer as contas. Para você atingir
6 mg de alta chanchantina através da
dieta, você precisaria comer
aproximadamente 150 g de salmão selvagem
do Alaska por dia, todo santo dia. E tem
que ser selvagem, porque o salmão de
cativeiro tem níveis muito mais baixos.
ou você poderia comer kg de camarão
diariamente, sem contar que o
processamento térmico reduz o conteúdo
de asta chantina. Então, na prática,
atingir níveis terapêuticos através da
alimentação é praticamente impossível
pra maioria das pessoas. A suplementação
não é preguiça, é pragmatismo baseado em
evidências. E aqui vai uma reflexão
importante sobre a medicina convencional
que eu preciso fazer. Enquanto a gente
tem piras e estudos mostrando os efeitos
da taxina na função mitocondrial,
proteção cardiovascular, saúde cerebral
e longevidade, o sistema médico
tradicional continua focado em gerenciar
sintomas com fármacos que têm efeitos
colaterais significativos e não abordam
as causas raiz. Eu não estou dizendo que
remédios não tem o seu lugar. Sim, eles
têm, óbvio que tem, mas quando você tem
um paciente com fadiga crônica e a
primeira linha de tratamento é
antidepressivo, em vez de investigar a
função mitocondrial e considerar
intervenções nutricionais suplementares,
alguma coisa está errada. A abordagem
integrativa que eu pratico não é
alternativa, é complementar e baseada em
fisiologia celular real. Tem uma
paciente minha chegou no consultório
reclamando de que estava perdendo
memória, se sentindo mentalmente lenta,
com aquela neva mental que não deixava
ela funcionar no ritmo que ela
precisava. Além disso, a pele dela
estava com aquele aspecto opaco e sem
vida. Impli um protocolo que tinha 12 mg
de rastachantina por dia junto com
outras intervenções para otimizar a
função mitocondrial. Depois de 4 meses,
ela não só relatou melhora significativa
na clareza mental e energia, como as
pessoas começaram a perguntar que
tratamento estético que tava fazendo.
Ela não tá fazendo nenhum tipo de
tratamento externo, era tudo de dentro
para fora. As mitocôndrias dela estavam
funcionando melhor, o estresse oxidativo
tinha reduzido, a inflamação baixou e
isso se refletiu tanto na cognição
quanto na aparência da pele. Outro ponto
que eu preciso abordar, exercício a
taxantina é particularmente interessante
para quem treina, seja recreacionalmente
ou competitivamente. Ela não só mostra
desempenho através de otimização
mitocondrial, melhora o desempenho, como
reduz marcadores de dano muscular e
acelera a recuperação. O estúdio de 2024
em atletas de endurance, que eu
mencionei antes, mostrou melhorias em
tempo de teste de ciclismo, medidas
cardiorrespiratórias e recuperação da
dor muscular de início tardio. Tem uma
preocupação teórica de que altas doses
de antioxidantes poderiam prejudicar
algumas adaptações fisiológicas ao
exercício, como biogênese mitocondrial,
mas até agora não há evidência de que a
sachantina causa esse problema. Na
verdade, parece promover a biogênese
mitocondrial oposto, que seria
problemático. Eu, particularmente, uso a
taxantina no meu próprio protocolo de
experimentação. Eu tenho 50 anos, treino
regularmente e quero maximizar não só
quantos anos eu vou viver. Health span,
não é só life span. Quando você olha pra
literatura científica de forma honesta,
a arta asantina se destaca como um dos
compostos com melhor relação risco
benefício disponível. O perfil de
segurança é excepcional. Os efeitos são
mensuráveis em múltiplos sistemas e o
custo benefício é excelente comparado
com muitas outras intervenções. Agora eu
preciso mencionar algumas ressalvas.
Primeiro, se você tá tomando
anticoagulantes, converse com seu médico
antes de experimentar sua chantina,
porque ela pode ter leves efeitos
antistrombóticos. Segundo, em doses
muito altas, algumas pessoas podem ter
leve desconforto grintestinal
transitório, embora isso seja raro nas
doses terapêuticas que estamos
discutindo. Terceiro, se você toma
outros suplementos hipossolúveis, como
vitaminas A, D e A e K, tome todos
juntos com gordura para otimizar a
absorção. E quarto, gestantes e
lactantes deve evitar ou usar apenas sob
super supervisão médica por falta de
estudos robustos nessas populações. Uma
coisa que eu gosto de fazer no
consultório é combinar esta chantina com
outros compostos que t sinergia pra
função mitocondrial e neuroproteção, por
exemplo, coisés, pqq, ácido alfa
alipoico, el carnina. Isso cria um
efeito de protocolo onde 1 mais 1 não é
dois, é três ou quatro. A medicina
funcional não trabalha com balas mágicas
isoladas, trabalha com protocolos
cinésicos que abordam múltiplas vias
simultaneamente. É assim que você
consegue resultados clínicos
significativos, não tratando sintomas
isolados com compostos únicos. E para
finalizar essa parte técnica, eu quero
que você entenda uma coisa fundamental.
Envelhecimento não é inevitável na
velocidade que a gente aceita como
normal. Muita coisa que a gente atribui
à idade é, na verdade, disfunção
mitocondrial acumulada, estresse
oxidativo crônico, inflamação
persistente e declino na capacidade de
reparo celular. Tudo isso pode ser
modulado. Eu não vou te prometer que
você vai viver até os 120 anos tomando a
taxantina. seria desonesto, mas eu posso
dizer, baseado em dados científicos
sólidos, experiência clínica real, que
você pode envelhecer com muito mais
saúde, energia e funcionalidade do que
seria seu destino sem intervenção. A
diferença entre alguém de 60 anos que
mal consegue subir escada sem ficar sem
fôlego e alguém da mesma idade
continuativo, mentalmente aguçado, com
aparência vibrante, não é só sorte
genética na maioria dos casos, é
resultado de decisões consistentes ao
longo de décadas sobre nutrição,
suplementação inteligente, exercício
adequado e gerenciamento estresse. A
asta chantina é uma dessas ferramentas
que quando implementada corretamente
dentro de um contexto maior de
otimização de saúde faz diferença real e
mensurável.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, assessorar
dosagens, omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
existe esse filtro. Compartilho os
exatos protocolos que eu uso na minha
clínica. Casos de reversão que parecem
possíveis, combinações of label que
funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Temos lives
semanais respondendo perguntas, PDF
exclusivo com 47 protocolos, grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer a visão funcional
real, sem simplificação para as massas,
clique em seja membro. E não é para
curiosos, é para quem quer resultados.
Agora, se você quer ir ainda mais fundo,
existe o nível dois. A cada duas semanas
nós fazemos live de imersão total, 2
horas de duração, desse artigos
científicos, linha por linha, debatendo
controvérsias que ninguém ousa tocar,
revelando os bastidores das pesquisas
que a indústria não quer que você
entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade de elite que
está reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria assiste passivamente,
você estará ao meu lado construindo
conhecimento de verdade, tendo o seu
reconhecimento público como alguém que
investe no que realmente importa. Não é
só sobre aprender, é sobre pertencer ao
ciclo interno de quem está mudando o
jogo. Poucos t a coragem. Você tem
agradecimentos especiais a nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube, nível
dois, Dr. Ana Paulo Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Burtinho, Fernando Machado,
Sou Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mares, Eloterapias
Integrativas, Luís Anselmo Neves Antes
da Doença. Eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado.